>> Sean: ARE BRINGING UP ONE
MORE TIME.
POLITICO.
JANUARY 11TH 2017.
UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO SABOTAGE
PROMPT BACKFIRED.
KEY OFFICIALS ARE SCRAMBLING TO
MAKE AMENDS WITH THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
POLITICO.
THEY ARE NOT CONCERNED.
THEY TRY TO HELP HILLARY AND
UNDERMINED CHOMPED TO PUBLICLY
QUESTION HIS FITNESS FOR OFFICE.
THEY SUGGESTED THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING THE MATTER.
A UKRAINIAN AMERICAN OPERATIVE
WAS CONSULTING FOR THE DNC.
HE MET WITH THESE OFFICIALS IN
THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY IN D.C.
AND AN EFFORT TO EXPOSE TIES AND
ET CETERA TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
PAUL MANAFORT, RUSSIA, AND IN
THE END, THE UKRAINIAN EFFORTS
HAD AN IMPACT IN THE RACE
HELPING TO FORCE MANNA FOR ITS
RUG IS NATION ADVANCING THE
NARRATIVE CLEARED THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US MR. MAYOR.
JOINING IS NOW, SENATE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN LINDSEY GRAHAM.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THIS.
>> I CAN IMAGINE IF MY TEMPTED
THAT HE MIGHT BE HEARING ALL
ABOUT IT BUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN SENT TO
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL LOOK AT ALL THINGS
BIDEN.
I HOPE SOMEBODY OUTSIDE OF
POLITICS WOULD DO TO THE BIDEN
TEAM WHAT THEY DID TO TRUMP.
LOOK AT IT REALLY HARD AND SEE
IF A CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
BUT HERE'S WHAT BOTHERS ME
TONIGHT.
THIS "NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
ABOUT BAR TALKING TO AUSTRALIA
IS THE BEGINNING OF AN
EFFORT TO SHUT DOWN VARS
INVESTIGATION TO FIND OUT HOW
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED AND LET
ME TELL YOU WHY.
I WANT TO SAY ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, BARR SHOULD BE
TALKING TO AUSTRALIA AND ITALY
AND THE U.K. TO FIND OUT IF
THERE INTELLIGENCE SERVICES
OPENED UP TO COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OF TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IF HE'S NOT DOING THAT, HE'S NOT
DOING HIS JOB SO I'M GOING TO
WRITE A LETTER TO ALL THREE
COUNTRIES AND ASKING THEM TO
COOPERATE WITH BARR.
THIS IS A LETTER SENT BY MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES IN MAY OF
2018 TO THE UKRAINIANS ARE
SAYING THAT IF YOU DON'T
COOPERATE WITH THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, WE ARE GOING TO
STOP OUR AID.
HERE'S WHAT I WANT AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW.
IT'S OKAY TO COOPERATE WITH
>> Sean: ON TO GET TRUMPED BUT
IT'S NOT OKAY TO COOPERATE WITH
BARR TO FIND OUT IF TRUMP WAS
THE VICTIM OF AN OUT-OF-CONTROL
INTELLIGENCE COOPERATION BEARD
WHEN I COULD HAVE A COUNTRY LIKE
THAT.
>> Sean: DO YOU BELIEVE AS I
BELIEVE THAT THE EVIDENCE WILL
SHOW WHAT PROBABLY EMERGED TO A
DURHAM OR DURHAM BAR REPORT THAT
HIGH RANKING INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS IN PART --    TWO ISSE
OFFICIALS IN PART --    TWO ISSS
HERE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THOSE THREE
SPECIFIC COUNTRIES, AUSTRALIA,
ITALY, GREAT BRITAIN, THAT THEY
WERE SPECIFICALLY OUTSOURCING OF
ILLEGAL SPYING.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY SUBTRACT
SUBCONTRACTED SPYING THAT IN
ORDER TO CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN
LAWS THEY SAID WE'LL USE BY
HONEST PERSON FOR ME?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT LIKELY
HAPPENED?
>> I DON'T KNOW BUT I KNOW WE
ARE GOING TO FIND OUT ABOUT THAT
IN TWO WEEKS AND I THINK BARR
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT BUT I
WANT TO MAKE THIS POINT REALLY
CLEAR.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE IS
AN EFFORT TO STOP THE BARR FROM
LOOKING AT HOW THIS WHOLE THING
BEGAN IN 2016 REGARDING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHAT ARE THEY AFRAID OF?
THIS REALLY BOTHERS ME A LOT
THAT THE LEFT IS GOING TO TRY TO
SAY THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
BARR TALKING TO AUSTRALIA,
ITALY, AND THE UNITED KINGDOM.
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT FOREIGN
PEOPLE BEING INVOLVED IN OUR
ELECTION, YOU ARE TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT CHRISTOPHER STEELE BEING
HIRED BY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND HERE'S MY QUESTION.
IS THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER, WHOEVER
HE OR SHE MAY BE, DO THEY HAVE
ANY CONNECTION TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THE OLD
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THAT WAS
CORRUPT AND FAILED?
THEY ARE CIA AGENTS OUT THERE
RISKING THEM LIVES BUT BRANDON
AND CLAPPER, I AM HOPING AND
PRAYING THAT SOMEBODY WILL
LOOK AT THE WAY THE INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION BEGAN.
IT WAS IT BASED ON STUFF COMING
FROM COUNTRIES FRIENDLY TO US?
>> Sean: WHEN WE WERE SPEAKING
WITH PRESIDENT ZELENSKY WHICH
WERE NEVER SHOULD BE ELITES,
OR NO FOREIGN LEADER IS GOING TO
WANT TO TALK ON THE PHONE
AGAIN, AND WE NEED THAT TO
HAPPEN, WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
I NEED A FAVOR.
WE'VE HAD THESE ELECTION
PROBLEMS AND YOU GUYS SEEM TO BE
IN THE CENTER OF IT ALL AND WE
EVEN HAVE POLITICO OUTLINING
HERE THAT THEY WERE ADMITTING
THAT THEY HELP HILLARY CLINTON
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO MAKE
AMENDS FOR THE WORK THAT THEY
DID TO SABOTAGE OUR ELECTIONS.
I THOUGHT EVERYBODY IN THE MEDIA
CARED ABOUT THAT BUT IT'S ONLY
IF IT'S DONALD TRUMP.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S
HILLARY'S DOSSIER AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER THAT IT'S UKRAINE TELLING
US THEY DID IT.
THEY INFLUENCE OUR ELECTION.
THERE WERE DEMOCRATIC OPERATIVES
THAT WENT TO THEM INCLUDED WITH
THEM FOR THE PURPOSE OF GETTING
DAMAGING INFORMATION.
ISN'T THAT PRETTY CLEAR AND OUT
POLITICO ARTICLE TO YOU SIR?
>> IT'S VERY CLEAR --
A COUPLE THINGS ARE CLEAR.
DEMOCRATS WANTED THE UKRAINE TO
WORK WITH MUELLER AND IF THEY
DIDN'T THEY WOULD CUT OFF THEIR
AID.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT LIBERALS
ARE STARTING AN ATTACK AGAINST
BARR TO SHUT HIM DOWN FROM GOING
TO ITALY, AUSTRALIA, AND THE
U.K. TO FIND OUT IF THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG REGARDING
OPENING UP THE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO BEGIN
WITH.
IF US ON A DOUBLE STANDARD, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WOULD BE.
SUCH WERE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR,
YOU ARE DOING THE COUNTRY A
GREAT SERVICE BY TRYING TO FIND
OUT WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016
REGARDING A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THESE COUNTRIES SHOULD BE
COOPERATING WITH BARR.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH HIM
LOOKING INTO IT.
AND AS A MATTER OF FACT, THERE
WOULD BE SOMETHING WRONG IF YOU
DIDN'T.
SO I'M GOING TO RIGHT TO THESE
COUNTRIES URGING THEM TO
COOPERATE.
>> Sean: WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
GET THE FINAL IG REPORT ON FISA
ABUSE BECAUSE HONESTLY IT'S
FUNNY BUT IT'S NOT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THAT WAS AN
UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER AND IT'S A
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
YOU KNOW, YOU THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU THINK OKAY WELL THEY CARE
ABOUT ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
THE POLITICO, RADIO, THEY TALK
ABOUT WHAT UKRAINE DID TO
INTERFERE IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
THEY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE WITH HILLARY'S
DIRTY DOSSIERS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY DIDN'T CARE THAT SHE
SCREWED BERNIE SANDERS OUT OF
THE PRIMARY.
THEY DIDN'T CARE THAT THEY
RIGGED AN INVESTIGATION POOCHIE
CLEARLY OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
I THINK IF I'D DELETED
SUBPOENAED EMAILS I'D BE IN DEEP
DEEP YOU KNOW WHAT SO WHAT ABOUT
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IN ALL OF
THIS?
>> WHAT ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER PEOPLE ARE AROUND